[Music]
okay what's the worst breakup I've ever
had I don't know I've been married for
too long you have a cat you're fine
I'm yeah I had a girl in high school who
was did that extra crazy thing where she
like we I was going to college and then
she had to stay back here and she was
like I miss you why aren't we together
you didn't I was like going to work and
trying for college sounds very sweet dan
I would did the romantic thing of
surprising her I like made the money for
the summer to go to college and then I
was like you know I got two weeks before
they let's go and see what she's up to
you know like click click open the door
her roommate was like oh my oh are you
doing here and then I like Shh and then
I went into a room and someone was there
Wow and then I realize her roommate was
not doing like oh my god what are you
doing here she was actually doing oh my
god what are you doing here so I was
like Miss reading the situation thing
where she was like crying on the phone
but like you know like that kind of
thing like she was doing the making me
crazy it seemed like it 17 I think yeah
what did you say am I surprised Oh like
blood blood blood no you should like
just send her like a construction worker
[Music]